bleiben bei yakuza und geben bald man so
auf jeden fall eine sehr fesselnd wie
bleiben sogar einen krankenhäuser oder
in krankenhäuser und es geht um ein
tabuthema ein thema die im frühjahr ein
bisschen aufgetaucht aber dann waren wir
als gesellschaft nicht wirklich in der
lage sie zu diskutieren am im
tagesspiegel stand am wochenende eine
art vor reportage ein arzt berichtet
dass sie seien klinik fast 90 prozent
der schwer kranken an prokopic 19
menschen mit migrationshintergrund sind
das hat wie la damals auch gesagt und
bezeichnete diese tatsache alles tabu
und ich frage mich warum sind wie immer
noch nicht in der lage wirklich über die
hintergründe zu sprechen mir geht es
nicht darum diese menschen
verantwortlich zu machen dass sie krank
werden oder jetzt irgendwie die rechte
zu bedienen dass die migranten
verantwortlich sind so die für die
krankheit und for coronary geht es darum
zu forschen warum diese menschen oft
krank werden schwerer krank werden und
ich komme aus israel und in israel 20
prozent arabischer israelis und wenn man
da die zahlen und die studios anschaut
dann sieht es nicht anders aus 50 bis 60
prozent der
menschen arabischer herkunft die in oder
menschen die ihnen an schwerkranken
koppelt sind sind araber und dass sie
zahlen die zeigen es gibt ein problem
und wenn man forscht dann wird man wird
man schon hintergrund befindet
ärgerliche begleit krankheiten die
bestimmten gruppen kommen f verhältnisse
mangel an vitamin d die in bestimmten
gruppen wie migranten auftauchen und
dazu führen dass diese menschen krank
sind wir sind aber jetzt moralischer wir
diskutieren nicht darüber damit wir
nicht die rechte bedienen und nehmen in
kauf dass menschen sterben und das hat
mit moral nichts zu tun
ich will da ist ein ganz ganz wichtigen
punkt den wir uns heute mitgebracht dass
ahmad vor allem finde ich ist auch ein
punkt über dem entsprechen muss wie sehr
die integration eigentlich auch wäre ein
crooner gescheitert ist ich finde dass
die menschen viel zu viel alleine
gelassen wurden ich habe mal als einer
kammer reporterin im flüchtlingsheim zum
beispiel gearbeitet
2017 war das und da war ich jeden abend
nicht nach hause gern habe eigentlich
nur noch geweint weil ich die so schlimm
fand wie die zustände dort waren wenn
ich mir heute vorstellen dass
beispielsweise die flüchtlingsheime noch
genauso sind das kann ich nicht
beurteilen ich war 2018 dort undercover
da muss ich wirklich sagen dann wundert
es mich nicht dass es dort zum beispiel
auch in den an mehr ausbrüche gab und
der sie muss man nicht mehr sagen was
hätte deutschland tun können damit
vielleicht die raten niedriger sind naja
in meine arbeit und ich mache diese
arbeit tagtäglich beobachtet dass manche
flüchtlinge offener für
verschwörungstheorien und fake news das
hat eigentlich mit ihrem misstrauen
gegenüber der staat und die erfahrungen
die sie auch mit regimes verbinden von
denen sie geflüchtet sind und das
bedeutet mehr aufklärung und wie gesagt
also wenn man weiß dass viele menschen
aus syrien mehr an diabetes erkranken
dass sie mehr herzprobleme bekommen
aufgrund von erst verhalten dass er
natürlich darf man das nicht für
allgemein wenn ich das weiß wenn ich das
artikulieren
dann kann ich gezielt mit hausärzte
arbeiten ich kann vielleicht auch
aufklärungsarbeit auf arabisch gehen ich
kann zu den menschen gehen ich kann sie
überzeugen sich zu impfen vielleicht
auch wie in ihren community vorbilder
für den schlechten wohnmöglichkeit einig
dass haben genau wie immer einfache
antwort das ist nur ein teil der
erklärung ich meine ist kollegen die
meinten ja sie verstehen nicht was die
nachrichten über corona sagen wir reden
hier über weltweite pandemie die gibt es
im nahen osten genau wie in deutschland
und jeder in dieser welt weiß was man zu
tun hat um sich zu schützen da geht es
um andere faktoren da geht es darum dass
diese menschen vielleicht auch mehr
kinder hatten es geht aber darum dass es
bestimmte faktoren mit dem kultur mit
den traditionen mit der art und weise
wie man lebt wie man ist welche
krankheiten man bekommt und das muss
erwähnt werden um diese leute zu retten
wie gesagt das geht nicht darum die
leute verantwortlich für diese krankheit
in sydney um menschenleben retten und da
passiert in deutschland viel zu wenig
weil wir uns nicht trauen die für
debatte zu verarbeiten sind jedoch
wieder so ein bisschen bei dem thema das
man fliege in diesem land nicht genügend
fördert in anderen ländern ist das was
sie ansprechen schlicht und ergreifend
der job der community hauses die eben
nicht erst einspringen wenn jemand
bedürftig geworden ist sondern die sich
fragen wie kann ich mein quarter meine
community kultur sensibel
gesundheit.de wende arbeitet
interdisziplinär arbeitet dinge die es
bei uns gar nicht gibt die kanada
finnland und sogar slowenien haben nur
hier sagt man
also du machst irgendwas mit
händchenhalten und kaffeetrinken und wir
wollen überhaupt gar nicht wissen was
uns da an leistungen von pflege entgeht
und gerade im kultur sensiblen bereich
währende quarters einfach das beste
gewesen weil dort ein
vertrauensverhältnis meistens schon seit
jahren besteht dann muss man eine
religion hausärzten aber jetzt nicht mit
hausärzten auch also das deutsche
gesundheitssystem ist jetzt nicht dafür
bekannt zu den schlechteren der welt zu
gehören aber so eigentlich ja ist ja
auch doch das ist teil aber wir haben
mit einer community zu tun die
reparaturmedizin betreibt das heißt wir
gehen erst zum arzt wenn man nicht mehr
kann und diese präventive dass man sich
untersucht das man guckt dass alles in
ordnung ist das ist nicht da weil sie
auch nicht aus einen staat kommen wo
diese gesundheitssystem so da ist also
was konkret schlagen sie vor sich
schlagen vor man sollte genau schauen
wie groß ist der anteil also was ist die
herkunft derjenigen die auf
intensivstationen beispiel offeriert
werden wahrscheinlich genauso sein
ich schlage vor dass wir erst mal
darüber diskutieren offen diskutieren
ich schlage vor dass man die
wissenschaft die möglichkeit die
freiheit gibt zu forschen das zu finden
was sind die gründe und ich schlage vor
kampagnen aufklärungskampagnen vor ort
da wo die menschen sind um sie vor vor
schutz zu gewinnen aber auch vor allem
für impfungen zu gewinnen was sie ja
richtig schon angedeutet haben ist ja
der punkt dass man da kein tabu drum
herum machen sollen macht man ja weiß
ich ja gegenseitig ja es ist richtig es
ist ein sprechen wenn es das so ist muss
man es binnen weil man kann so ein
problem nur behalten wenn man auch offen
dazu spricht und wenn man das wieder
alles verleugnet dann kommt gleich die
verschwörungstheoretiker die dahinter
wieder was vermutet einen politischen
ansatz wegen teile ich diese auffassung
dass muss man aufklären kramer schauen
aber muss man auch sehen dass regional
unterschiedlich ich habe mich noch mal
kundig im vorfeld der sendung bei uns in
unserem universitätsklinikum das sind
die meisten patienten die einen kurs
erkranken und auf der intensivstation
liegen einfach leute die schlicht nicht
geimpft sind und ohne
migrationshintergrund sind ja auch an
wenn ich damals ansetzung der
gesellschaft vielleicht und wie viele
migranten der gerade da sind ich bin
auch eine rolle aber sind noch zwei
gruppen müssen wirklich beide kümmern
und das ist aufklärung wichtig kein tabu
machen sondern was man auch ganz am
anfang der sendung gesagt haben wirklich
drüber reden und nur so kriegt man auch
verständnis dafür deswegen ist es gut
dass sie das ansprechen offenheit da
sind wir beim thema meinungsfreiheit und
was sagt bar in dieser bundesrepublik
und jahr
2021 und ich finde es bezeichnen in so
vielen debatten dass diese verengung der
diskurs so brutal geworden ist dass wir
in kauf nehmen dass menschen sterben
statt dass wir über das thema sprechen
[Musik]